[Music]
[Music]
demi lovato and max eric
may have called off their engagement but
these x's
are anything but stone cold oh thank you
in fact both demi and max still have
plenty of pda
and engagement picks up on their insta
pages
and they're keeping it positive on
social media after breaking it off
news broke thursday that the couple had
called it quits
a source told et quote it was a tough
decision
but demi and max have decided to go
their separate ways to focus on their
respective careers
they have respect and love for one
another and will always cherish
the time they spent together shortly
after the news broke
the 29 year old young and the restless
star took to instagram to post
a simple message quote jesus loves you
on thursday morning demi shared this
promotional post about her collab with
talkspace
and if you look closely she's still
sporting that engagement bling
but it's worth noting it's unclear when
that photo was taken
but after fans learned they had called
things off
the 28 year old shared a video on her ig
story in glam
without her ring rocking a shirt that
reads
dogs over people
the sorry not sorry singer and the actor
first started dating in march
and in july max popped the question
i'm really excited earlier this month
demi gushed over falling in love during
the pandemic
we were able to share this time together
that we wouldn't have normally gotten to
spend and
that accelerated our relationship on a
level that you know you can't really
explain to people but quarantine either
makes or breaks you and it really made
it better so
i'm really um really blessed really
fortunate and
continuing to count my blessings every
day